there's a sequence in a plate tail
requiem's fourth chapter where you're
forced to flee a literal tsunami of rats
as you jump from one stone rooftop to
another the swarm of plague-infested
vermin sweeps through the town below
like raging flood waters toppling over
buildings at their foundation and
consuming anyone caught in its
destructive path it's a moment of
Hollywood spectacle that showcases the
remarkable advancements in technology
since a playtale innocence was released
in 2019 whereas the first game could
handle 5 000 rats at any one time its
sequel can populate the screen with a
staggering 300 000. this vast
multiplication enhances the terrifying
and oppressive nature of the series
signature rodents but moments like this
are an outlier for the most part Requiem
feels very familiar to its predecessor
[Music]
although developer asobo Studio has
supplemented its stealth Action gameplay
with a few new additions this sense of
familiarity persists throughout the
first half of the game like innocence
Requiem puts you in the well-worn shoes
of amicia a teenage girl who's tasked
with protecting her younger brother Hugo
as they Traverse a plague-stricken 14th
century France in search of a cure for
his mysterious illness amicia is armed
with a sling that can both kill
helmetless enemies and strike crates of
conveniently placed armor to create a
distraction you'll also have access to
alchemical ammo that can either light
fires or snuff them out letting you
navigate through the Mischief of light
averse rats and use them to your
advantage by shrouding enemies in the
darkness amicia is a more proficient
fighter this time around so you'll be
able to strike armored enemies after
being spotted and lead them stunned for
a few seconds if you have a single use
knife handy you can finish them off with
a killing blow but knives are hard to
come by and also double as a tool for
opening padlocked workbenches these
hidden stashes are filled with various
crafting materials so I always found it
more advantageous to hold on to any
knives I could get my hands on rather
than wasting them on a single kill you
can also use a mesia sling to strangle
unarmed enemies by catching them unaware
from behind there's an element of risk
and reward in doing so however since the
animation is fairly lengthy it's not
completely quiet as a result of a
messia's fragility most Encounters in
Requiem demand a stealthy approach such
as sneaking through Tall Grass crawling
under carts and throwing pots to divert
prying eyes when you're not utilizing
rats to Devour the soldiers in your way
this distraction-based stealth isn't the
most interesting and hasn't really
evolved since innocence it makes sense
with the context of the game and sells
the Relentless situation amicia and Hugo
are in as the odds are stacked against
them and their entire existence ascend
actually boils down to escaping death
over and over again but the environments
you're in are often fairly linear and
cramped so your Avenues of approach are
severely limited unlike the first game
you can at least re-enter stealth after
being caught by running away losing line
of sight and hiding but these early
areas don't offer enough space to make
this feasible so restarting the section
is usually your best option upon
detection fortunately the game starts to
stretch its legs about five hours in and
this also coincides with the
introduction of a few more tools and
abilities for you to play with amicia
eventually gains access to a deadly
crossbow that can kill most armored
enemies with a single bolt to offset the
weapon's power ammunition is scarce so
it's not something you'll be using often
but Hugo has a more reliable way of
dispatching any enemies in your path
Rats the disease he's Afflicted with has
gradually deepened his connection with
the plague carrying rodents giving you
the chance to discreetly control them
and violently consume those unprotected
by light
there's something to think disturbingly
satisfying about watching a Mischief of
rats wash over people until there's
almost nothing left although controlling
them is limited by a gauge that fills
with use putting Hugo's powers out of
action for a while once filled amicia
and Hugo's circumstances make it
difficult for the pair to trust anyone
they are often joined on their Travels
by a number of companions who help out
in either stealth or combat Arno for
instance is a Gruff soldier who can be
directed to fight enemies with the Press
of a button he reliably wins one-on-one
duels within a few moves but he's loud
and you'll need to lend a helping hand
if he gets surrounded otherwise he'll
die and trigger a game over Sophia on
the other hand is a pirate you meet in
the latter half of the game she comes
equipped with a Shard of glass that can
be used to deflect sunlight and set dry
grass on fire these new toys add Renewed
Energy and a semblance of strategy to
encounters specially in areas where the
game opens up and allows you to navigate
past enemies in more ways than one aside
from offering multiple paths through a
section these larger Maps also encourage
you to adopt a particular playstyle
which is further incentivized by
requiem's skill system by opting for the
pacifist roof for example and sneaking
past enemies without being spotted or
killing anyone you'll unlock skills
geared towards improving your stealth
abilities such as increasing your speed
when crouched and dampening the amount
of noise you make when you move if
you're aggressive on the other hand
you'll gain access to abilities
including a push that lets you shove
enemies into fire or rats and another
that speeds up the amount of time it
takes to choke out foes with the mesia's
slang you can mix and match approaches
to unlock skills in each category so
there's an element of Freedom present in
how you shape amicia's repertoire
there's also some light puzzle solving
sprinkled throughout that never get too
complicated and usually revolves around
using various light sources to Traverse
through rat infested areas these moments
provide a welcome change of pace
although there are few too many instinct
instances where you need to push carts
in order to climb up and reach higher
levels which feels both contrived and
archaic similarly there are a number of
moments where you're forced into
confined combat scenarios where the only
way through is by killing everyone in
your path the role these sequences play
in requiem's story is impactful as it
Chronicles shifting attitude since the
first game and tackles the struggles and
guilt she faces with each life she's
forced to Snuff out but from a gameplay
perspective they offer a little more
than frustrating trial and error combat
isn't especially difficult but the game
likes to punish you in order to
underline amicia's fragility it feels
like there's a correct path through
these sequences and you'll die over and
over again until you can figure out what
it is missteps like this are
disappointing not least because there's
so much to love about Requiem story and
setting the narrative picks up six
months after the first game ended with
the Mision Hugo traveling to a region of
province in southern France bordering
the Mediterranean Sea it's the beginning
of summer so this new setting infuses
the game with a abundance of color and
vibrancy that wasn't present in the
original it's utterly beautiful at times
with sunkiss Fields bursting with the
color of lavender and daffodil flowers
bustling markets draped in black and
yellow banners and Windswept cliffsides
looking over an incoming thunderstorm
war and rat carrying plagues are yet to
puncture this region of France so the
game takes every opportunity to capture
These Quiet Moments where you're
surrounded by the veracity of life and
nature at its core Requiem feels like a
game of stark contrast the picturesque
setting and mesmerizing sites it
frequently conjures makes the influx of
sudden violence all the more impactful
while also adding another element of
Terror to the darkness of night you'll
enter a town where people are shopping
at a Florist Stall or taking in a street
performance with exuberant Glee and
witnessing this makes it hit harder when
the rats warm in and leave the bare
corpses of those same people in their
wake you see it reflected in Hugo too
where the innocence of his childhood
Glee clashes with his harrowing
circumstances whether it's because he's
wrestling with his disease and
connection to the rats exploding in
Anger at the world's cruelty or
struggling to deal with the horrible
things he's seen omician Hugo's
characterization is at the heart of
requiem's story and propels the
narrative forward even when it
occasionally stumbles there's a sequence
about halfway through where the game's
Relentless Pace slows to a crawl so it
can dump a load of exposition this could
have been tightened up and shortened
particularly since the game's last
couple of hours feel overly drawn out
these are my only nitpicks with the
story though the performances across the
board are excellent and I appreciate its
authentic portrayal of anxiety and panic
attacks as the consequences of their
traumatic experiences finally catching
up with amicia it can seem cruel at
times but Requiem tells a heart-rending
and Powerful story that's worth seeing
through to the end this is where the
familiarity Creeps in again as the same
exact thing can be said about the first
game a playtail Requiem excels in the
same areas its predecessor did its
stealth Action gameplay is uneven but
has at least improved introducing more
tools for you to play around with and
expanding in scope to provide more
interesting Avenues to explore when it
comes to traversing past threats both
human and rodent alike the rats are
still its most memorable feature
bursting from the floor like geysers and
in more numbers than ever before there's
a lot to love in Requiem even if
frustration is an all too common
bedfellow when it comes to gameplay
there are better stealth games out there
but its unique setting poignant
storytelling and rat infested dread make
14th century France worth returning to
whoa very pretty
so this is where my kingdom stops that
branches your Frontier yes
yes why not
a dozen enemy Ships coming
they're going to attack us oh no what do
we do
stay in the frontier and sing them
before they pass